c'est un musée qui se visite à 6 ou les
oeuvres des files devant les spectateurs
et se découvre ensuite du bout du doigt
c'est une oeuvre vous intéresse vous
appuyez sur la petite icône de la
tablette et du coup vous allez avoir sur
la première page le cartel qui explique
qu'elle est l'oeuvre et ensuite une
explication de l'oeuvre ou vraiment
on vous donne tous les détails toutes
les infos des peintures des sculptures
mais aussi de la danse et de la musique
provenant des plus illustres c'est les
musées nationaux comme l'opéra de paris
le château de versailles ou encore le
musée d'orsay
c'est autre chose que le musée mais je
suis allé voir tout temps canon à la
villette à paris
trop de monde déjà et les gens prennent
pas le temps de regarder les sujets ni
foule ni files d'attentes ni flash mais
de l'interactivité et même une totale
immersion
grâce à la technologie numérique cela
s'était très bien c'était ma première
expérience en réalité virtuelle
c'est intéressant les enfants ont l'air
plus à l'aise que nous on est un peu
vieillot nommé mots il arrive quand même
y arrive
objectif de ce musée pas comme les
autres démocratiser la culture et
rapprocher l'art de ceux qui en sont
éloignées
c'est la distance et le transport pour
se rendre à paris même si nous ne sommes
pas très loin il faut quand même
il y allait se rendre payer le prix du
billet du musée et puis peut-être une
certaine appréhension de ce qu'on peut
trouver dans les musées et du coup micro
folie ça permet d'avoir ce premier
contact avec les oeuvres d'art après
dreux et courtenay la micro folie de
pithiviers et la troisième à voir le
jour en centre val de loire
le ministère de la culture espère en
ouvrir 200 dans toute la france